with over 300 sessions at next 2018 it's
understandable you can get to them all
so if you didn't see how to do
predictive analytics and bigquery then
stay tuned because here's the rewind you
can now do machine learning and write in
bigquery and you're about to see what
that looks like but first what's all the
fuss about bigquery is Google clouds
enterprise class data warehouse if you
have petabytes of data you can analyze
all of it with a single query and
standard sequel and you can even do
real-time analytics the best part is
that bigquery is serverless and fully
managed which means that all you need to
think about is what data you have and
how you want to analyze it machine
learning is an algorithmic approach to
making repeated decisions with data and
it's incredibly useful it lets you
automate a whole new classes of tasks
and create business-critical prediction
systems to make machine learning work
you need data and algorithms putting
them together gives you models for
making predictions so if you were
waiting for the catch there it is this
little thing about putting them together
can actually be much harder than it
sounds
data fuels machine learning it's what
makes machine learning tick and you have
it in bigquery now you've got to get
your data into machine learning software
and your data set is not small how do
you get a copy of your whole beast of a
multi petabyte data set into tens of
flow in order to get that sophisticated
model year after now you're back to
thinking about infrastructure at scale
again which is what you are trying to
avoid in the first place so instead of
bringing your data to machine learning
you can help bring machine learning to
your data right and big query that's
what bigquery ml is all about and it
supports linear and logistic regression
so that means forecasting and
classification just got easy here's what
housing prediction looks like and as an
added bonus you get those model
evaluation functions you know and love
including the ROC curve what you're
looking at here is the data studio
version but we've got liquor integration
- making it easy to explore data create
models operationalize your ml workflow
with looker bigquery ml means that
machine learning at scale is no longer
just for huge teams of data scientists
and data engineers and the possibilities
are endless there's so many applications
just waiting for you to dive in in the
full talk you'll get inspired by
for customer use cases and you'll hear
directly from Hearst as they tell their
bigquery ml story and of course you'll
get to see bigquery ml in action in the
live demo if you'd like to see the full
talk check out the link in the
description below and don't forget to
subscribe to the cloud YouTube channel
for more great next rewind content
thanks for watching
[Music]